well to a developing story this evening
that prince andrew has requested a trial
by jury to settle the civil case that
has been brought against him by virginia
du frey let's speak to our u.s
correspondent martha kellner who's
following the case and what is the
significance of this then martha
yeah anna this is a formal response
andrew and his lead lawyer andrew
brettler to this civil suit brought
against him by virginia zhu frey it's
the first time they've engaged with
these complaints these claims made by
virginia's eufray in their full detail
just as a reminder virginia's euphrate
claims she was trafficked around the
world by the pedophile jeffrey epstein
and the convicted sex trafficker guillen
maxwell and forced to have sex with rich
and powerful men including prince andrew
in this filing he formally denies those
claims that virginia's you frey
has made he also perhaps that the most
interesting bit of this document is the
bit that says he demands a trial by jury
just to get the exact wording um of that
for you he says
prince andrew hereby demands a trial by
jury on all causes of action asserted in
the complaint now this is
sort of standard legal procedure in that
virginia's euphrate had already
requested a trial by jury and prince
andrew is agreeing to that demand um so
it means that if this trial
if this case apologies does reach a
trial it will be heard by a jury
of course it's important to remember
that in america 95 of these civil cases
don't ever reach the stage where they're
heard in court in a trial so that in
itself um would be remarkable
but virginia's you phrase lawyer david
boyes uh implied that he would welcome
um he would welcome being the the chance
to face prince andrew in court he's
released a statement saying
prince andrew's answer continues his
approach of denying any knowledge or
information concerning the claims
against him and purporting to blame the
victim of the abuse for somehow bringing
it on herself we look forward to
confronting prince andrew with his
denials and attempts to blame mizu frey
for her own abuse at his deposition and
at trial
the next stage of this process if it
continues without any settlement out of
court and there is no indication at the
moment that that would happen there
would be a deposition which means prince
andrew would face mr boys virginia's you
phrase lawyers and have to answer
questions about the claims that she's
making against him if it does go ahead
to trial it could happen as soon as
september although there is some
flexibility in that process it could
carry on to next year but certainly this
situation not drawing to a close any
time soon
martha updating us there from washington
thank you